he said it himself he feels like he can
catch up to anybody's fastball and when
you have that feeling as a hitter
another base hit
fell behind o2
took two pitches that he may not have
taken as recently as a year ago
got the count even and got something
over the middle of the plate and another
base hit seven consecutive hits for
byron buxton
he homered in his last at-bat in the
second game in cleveland went five for
five on wednesday and now we'll base it
to start this game
and there he goes the pitch is near the
outside corner and buxton is out at
second base
and i don't even think salvador perez is
convinced of that he's staying behind
home plate
well he got a good pitch to throw on
perez jumped up
but the twins aren't going to challenge
it
maybe this view
there yeah it looked like the the oven
mitt was going in there and any single
will score by her buck
singers misses have been non-competitive
and then quality strikes hasn't been a
lot in between
and arise is hit by a pitch
and a run will score
and another misfire but if you're gonna
get hit you may as well drive in a run
and hit him and look like probably the
arm or maybe the rib cage a little bit
yeah as we said his misfires have been
kind of all over the place well 40
pitches just 18 strikes and remember
what
into the buxton at bat it was like nine
pitches seven strikes so
take a listen to this
and now donaldson will hit with the
bases loaded nieces loaded one out one
in
and donaldson hits it back to the middle
got singer on the foot
and
[Music]
a throw down to second base and now to
the plate
and
everybody's trying to figure out what's
going on here singer goes down that
i think the question was did it
hit his foot and then go into the air or
did it hit the ground
and then shoot up into the air the
runners all froze you know i'm not sure
where he hit it we'll just have to where
he got hit but
either way it's a double play
and
brady it's good thing he's on his feet
limping off we'll see what happens in
the next inning now kirloff's got
another opportunity this time
with nobody out runners on first and
second hit that ball his first time off
106 miles an hour
onto the warning track hoping it was
going to go over the fence
high fly left field benintendi going
back carol off has his first
a three-run home run
wanted it bad
for alex carrillo
i got chills that's that's such a great
feeling right there that's that's
awesome he was so excited he almost
passed crews on the bases
there's no better feeling than that
right there you've been waiting your
whole life you know since you hit up
picked up a bat and hit off the tee and
that's a tremendous weight lifted off
his shoulders right there the man hit
some balls hard but he went over 15
before he got his first hit and tonight
he got his first home run yeah it looked
like they were trying to go in on him
but
you see him look at it he's going is it
enough he's watching it as he's going up
the line
but on that first one on that first one
you're not sure
you want to see that thing go over the
wall and
[Laughter]
there's that smile
you know they love
the
energy you fans bring them
[Music]
carlos santana is going to hit one into
the upper deck in right center field to
put the royals on the board
here they come
pitches actually it was a fastball 91
had a little run to it but he barreled
it
to hit it that far
buxton just turned and watched it
and upper tank
[Music]
that's hit to center buxton coming in
and a diving catch in center
oh what a catch maybe his best of the
year
that was incredible i didn't think he
had any chance at getting to this ball
then attendee was out front he hit this
ball off the end of the bat
and he was shading towards left center
[Applause]
that was i mean absolutely incredible
his jump his
concentration into here playing the
superman music in the in the ballpark is
as fitting as it gets but i mean he's
continuing to do it all
for this twins ball club it's impressive
to watch
nice to get that first one out of the
way and hopefully help him settle in a
little bit more it kind of changes the
lineup and how you have to pitch to
these guys
high and deep to center field taylor
back
he's got another one carol off to
straight away center field
and it's five to one this one a change
up out there it does a nice job of
staying on it and
get out get out get out here as he goes
up the line but what a day i mean he
took that pressure off and and now he
just looks relaxed and he's doing
exactly kind of what he expects himself
to do
ben attendee looked like he was a
fixture with a high fly center field and
now buxton going back
at the warning track at the wall leaping
and making it another catch
[Applause]
he's just taking it over
with the bat
with the glove
with the arm he can do it all
there goes kepler arnold ball lash to
the gap in right center and with the
runner going kepler will be waved around
third simmons drilling one to the gap
he'll hold up with an rbi double
break vets able to check in and get his
first hit right here as well
dump behind third there's his first base
hit and his first run batted in
and he gets a nice ovation from this
crowd you see everybody on their feet
giving them a hand
and that gets away from perez
and a run will score
rorbett with a lot of firsts here in the
eighth inning his first hit his first
run batted in his first run scored
high fly
center field
tagging is a rise coming in is taylor
there's the catch here's the throw and
it's coming through and just barely safe
is the rise
[Applause]
sacrifice fly for crews in the fourth
run of the inning
fly ball left field arise
charging toward the line and a diving
catch in fair territory to end the game
twins flashing leather all over the
field oh this ball arrives ran a long
way for this ball terrific play when it
ended up fair and
defense was there all night the bullpen
did a great job pineda did a great job
and
they win the opener of the series
and the home stand
and the bullpen did an awfully nice job